I thought that was it my days were over
two years ago Sandra got the news so
many people dragged a cancer diagnosis
with that came fears for the worst well
as soon as you hear that word cancer you
automatically think your days are
numbered just start to crying and I just
said I was going to let nature take its
course
but my husband said
got to stop think about it I got to
think about him
and my grandchildren
and I did
thankfully the things she did made her
story different
the disease was detected early thanks to
a quick lung scan five minutes away from
home
saved my life I can't thank these people
enough and it's it's a fabulous scheme
that life-changing two-minute check was
in one of these a mobile long truck
aimed at areas are more deprived like
parts of South Yorkshire
sort of program a lot of people
especially people up here what would
have absolutely no no chance of getting
cured for anything really that disparity
means poorer communities suffer with the
worst figures on early detection and the
lowest survival rates for lung cancer
statistics the NHS says it is now
completely reversed in 12 months it used
to be that people who were least well
off were most likely to have lung cancer
at an advanced stage when we found it by
taking these CT scans to people in that
group and by diagnosing lung cancer
earlier than ever before we've actually
turned that trend on its head so people
who are least well-off are now more
likely to have their lung cancer
diagnosed at an early stage than anybody
else
thanks to a targeted intervention Sandra
is still here with this advice for
anyone given the chance to get checked
you've got to go and have the skunk
because you just never know shingi
marike Sky News Doncaster